[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to let's
talk about Sonic the Hedgehog I'm
required to say before devianart the
iconic Sega Genesis character not only
has several hit games in the 90s but
also two successful TV shows both on at
the same time heels I can't think Batman
the Animated Series and Batman the 60s
show both on simultaneously
it was strange but kind of cool as the
years went on though sonic gradually
slipped making clumsy games with clumsy
storylines what you didn't want to see
Sonic turn into a werewolf or make out
with Final Fantasy foldouts
Oh some of you did I'm most required
again to say there is no devianart in
this video why do I simply have ten
emails of inflated Sonic's despite this
or maybe in light of this Sonic has
grown a very large fanbase online his
reputation is odd to say the least
just because I don't understand
something doesn't mean it's bad and I'm
gonna take a wild guess and say there's
stranger things online well I should
like Google car from The Jungle Book I
see no reason why not
Oh God okay we're getting on topic my
point is people have been asking me to
review Sonic media for years but all
I've gotten up to is the Sonic SatAM
show I'm really seeing any of the new
shows or play many of the new games
after that but then somebody brought up
that there's a sonic movie no not that
one not that one neither though here the
force gun soldier is very good in that
I'm talking about the anime OVA
[Music]
primary in Japan in 1996 this got a
video release in America around 1999 so
not even an hour long all the
advertisements clearly label it as the
Sonic the Hedgehog movie so I guess it
counts does it lure newcomers into the
mix does it please diehard loyalists is
there room for my fan character in a
sonic Critic wouldn't roll let's take a
look at the Sonic the Hedgehog ova movie
oh come on they don't even have the
singers going say that's the credits
roll we see Metal Sonic seems to have
been built by dr. wily i me Robotnik I
mean Eggman I mean you know what dr.
wily this is all just a furry version of
Megaman think about it small blue hero
stuffs big moustache scientist who takes
over robots has a dog a girl and a ton
of sequels people hate you laughs I
ponder we cut to Sonic who resides in an
area of activity where tails his psychic
slash child slash adult slash fiction is
off to use his surfboard you let it try
it out no right now thanks tails is just
like a little kid with his new toy
I bet a lot of you thought he was a
little kid let me unconvince by
explaining nothing oh and I mean nothing
there are no intros for anyone we're
just supposed to already know who
everyone is and what their
characteristics are I mean all
scientists and rocket ships clearly
explain themselves the very least you
could throw in some Looney Tunes
introductions even something as little
as this could help
[Music]
Wow even shorter than I thought
no Sonic saves the both of them as the
owl scientist let sonic know that he's
needed business all right it's a real
emergency you see the president do I
feel like they came up with the elves
voice the same day they recorded your
recording the owl scientists go I
thought I was just delivering blow
you're a voice actor now go you've done
this before question my life choices yes
he wants us to come to the Verizon and
chill house right away
you know it might have been easier if
you just called to tell us that I mean
do we have phones we don't seem to have
clothes that cover our genitalia I would
just really advanced nudists but either
a drunk Teddy Roosevelt as president or
Robotnik has taken over hi everybody hi
Robotnik please accept a small token of
my gratitude
but for the sake of my daughter and
everyone else listen to him it seems
Robotnik has the president and his
daughter captured which is usually the
third act of a movie and not usually the
first couple minutes now Sonic I've got
the upper hand this is about the entire
planet of freedom so you better do as I
say Oh so kidnapping the president was
just an attention getter Sonic must be a
real asshole actually I'm not too far
off Robotnik says he actually needs help
because a robotic version of him took
over his lair and a generator of energy
has to be stopped before it blows up the
world our dickhead of a hero could care
less
Oh get about it why should I have to go
around sleeping up you're fine don't
blame me when this happens I thought it
was nice that they keep those dyslexic
Batman sound effects a home sonic please
dude we find out quickly though that
everyone's kind of a taint in this
universe sonic I don't care what happens
to rebonding or daddy but please just do
this for the two of us Wow first thing
bitch second thing are you two an item
now they try that in another game the
results were ue nice
I'm working through things dark thing
Sonic agrees for whatever disturb
relationship he has with Sara Ella
botany gives Tails a watch to get him to
his lair using this
don't thank me just blow your nose you
sound like a constipated Simpson child
tails do you actually trust that
ridiculous little gadget that Robotnik
built for you that's not a robotic is
the only person who knows where
metropolis is so we have to use
navigator bells they work Wow that was
probably the most anime line delivery
the movies had yet I'm just going to say
words until I run out of words and that
these words are going to stop me in
Words Words i guess so confusingly back
with the president the video game
characters are playing video game
characters just give up we've played a
hundred times I'll stop being your
hostage alright started again okay one
of us is an idiot we then come back to
tails and sonic
thank God we did that back to video
games apparently one of Robotnik's pods
drops in and both Sara and Robotnik hop
in I just want to make sure we are high
right now right Sonic and Tails come
across some tough wins and end up
crashing
- lambic Thanks never throw all the
traps laid out for them and free the
animals inside the robots like in the
game or just disembowel them we'll just
assume they used to be bad they get to
robotropolis after crossing some ancient
relics indicating that Sonic the
Hedgehog takes place in our currency
futures finally the adventure time
crossover we never knew we wanted and
will wish stay that way we should hurry
it tails always act like a kid when
there's lightning but apparently he
isn't I don't know but metal Robotnik
appears to try and stop I'm gonna do it
again
that's literally all you do does sonic
play Sonic games he grows a rocket pack
and wings and tries to hunt them down
don't think you're safe yet I'm well
aware that neither one of you can swim
or maybe you can you just play really
anxiety-provoking music whatever you're
about to drop my bottle still crunches
every time I do that you didn't think
I'd fall fresh stupid trick like that
did you
okay am i seeing that wrong or is he
shooting bullets on them that must be
some devilish Taco Bell you had earlier
Metamucil you'll be shooting bullets for
a week keep fires missiles as well to
totally eradicate Sonic easily the end
of a cure didn't have explosion that big
they were calling the Blue Boar because
that's what he would look like just
standing there sonic does survive for
reasons and knuckled Isle Dundee comes
in to help out
sonic behold
robotnik and Sarah arrived though as
Robotnik claims sonic will have more to
worry about
he'll have to fight something far more
evil than metal you better keep your
hands off my Sonic or I'll never forgive
you
okay does my sonic mean hedgehog or
hedge cuz either way I'm very disturbed
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
so Sonic Tails and Knuckles get to Robo
trap Alice where they come across okay
even by sonic designs that's lazy it's
being a wish to us but bother get to
incorporate his face into everything
seriously what make in the way of the
function after a while I want my face on
that machine we can paint it on no my
mustache has to be the gears and my eyes
the measuring rods that compromises the
efficiency of blue hedgehog could easily
destroy it okay you're the face of the
company copies my face if they come
across metal sonic who now has Sonic's
abilities which were copied while he was
in that machine metal sonic element to
look at him is actually kind of
intimidating a little granted he's
designed like an even Gillian Marvin the
Martian your planet's blocking of Venus
result in termination isn't that lovely
Nick and Sarah rhyme on the scene
that part was rewound so what about this
blue lock Robotnik way to keep it classy
Robotnik you came all the way here and
now your guy here I'm going to use metal
to destroy the real sonic until I can
completely destroy the land of the sky
so I'm not sure why he made this fake
mission to defeat Sonic when he already
had him and the president in perfect
executable positions but now level sonic
is after him
he has the power to turn into eighties
music videos watch it here take on me
again the robot do the robot
that's mecha meta I'm not a scientist I
can't understand that technical jargon
looks like that's it whoa does robotic
have a Muppets Satan setting sonic will
never again be a pain in my eggs wait am
I called Eggman yet oh who cares the
parents kind of get it Metal Sonic also
has plans for Sonic's friends back home
sonic I question expect you back so soon
wait what are you doing
not even the howling survived some
Robotnik starts is um second attack on
the president's home could this be the
work of metal Robotnik well worth three
fours in might as well have an inner
monologue with a character so secondary
you could calm core Denari but it looks
like Metal Sonic didn't destroy the owl
and instead turn him into a painful
reminder of when this was made he forced
me to put on these clothes and I
suddenly want to extreme capri-sun
skydive good burger anyone else and
since there's no better time we'll be
the only ones left then we can get
married Kara's the reason I gave you
that dress is because it's an anime
where did the third act
we need obscured options
I'll give credit that's the most
imaginative way I've seen that done
you're a perfect target for me now box
enemy fighters coming at you fire
ok even the smoke debris has his face
here I'm gonna kill Sonic with the
Hedgehog seeking missile years ago but
couldn't find a way to work his ugly mug
onto it knuckles and Tails save Serah
but big shock things get sexually
awkward tails get off I never thought
you'd stoop that low
Wow well can't act like I'm shocked I
have to play this
there's nothing more cool than being
hugged by someone you like but if
someone tries to touch you in a place or
in a way that makes you feel
uncomfortable that's no good I was like
a cowboy with a gun holster with that
clip but Sonic and Metal Sonic continue
to fight would you try for me brave man
would you do it for a Sarah snack right
yes ma'am
how come we're not freezing to death
everybody tries to help Sonic out and
she is sitting on his face
what the hell Japan you were giving kids
no chance to have a normal sex life Wow
they knock out Metal Sonic but then the
president comes in to make things more
complicated
the president's timing couldn't be worse
I think that's what presidents
specialize in tails tries to get the
president out while Metal Sonic gets
back up and continues to fight Oh
a thumbs down in Japan that's like a
thumbs down they get the president out
and Sonic ends up roasting the metal
headache
you are the chosen one grab ahold of my
hand
I didn't realize that I loved him
confused well we didn't learn jack
what so now we're finally even Sonic
because that's what it's all about
repressed sexual aggression like to hear
you make an argument for anything else
yeah I wouldn't announce that so proudly
I'd be more like sobbing because brother
this was weird the animation is nice as
well as the backgrounds but this is an
overly complicated story with either too
little character or too much presumption
that we already know what these people
are like I guess I can't be too angry at
it as it plays exactly like what it is a
giant commercial it's not obnoxiously
annoying and there's nothing offensive
dish but it just feels empty and
pointless I can see some kids having fun
with it but for the fastest hedgehog
alive this could have been a lot more
interesting and a lot more cool get on
your running shoes and dash away from
this as fast as possible
or a sonic SEZ would say first yes say
no then you get out of it I've noticed I
sure could a guy remember so you don't
have to
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing the
Alliance for the Great Lakes and once
again this ties in to our newest show
we're doing called what you can do that
shows how you can volunteer at different
organizations and charities and that's
when we're doing this week so we're just
gonna show a little snippet of it if
you'd like to donate to it the link is
right there or if you like to volunteer
you know great links is a very it's very
very big so definitely look into it and
see if you want to volunteer here's a
little snippet of some of the great work
that they do my name is Tyrone Dobson
and I'm the volunteer manager for the
Alliance for the Great Lakes and what
are you guys doing out here today we're
doing a beach cleanup today so we do our
adoptive each program is one of our
longest running programs we serve as
15,000 volunteers each year and those
volunteers last year picked up 36,000
pounds of trash and so they're doing
work all over the Great Lakes so in all
eight states that border the Great Lakes
we have volunteers cleaning up all year
long it kind of gives you a sense of
pride because you see your city coming
together to really make good work we
were sitting here we're like oh man if
the weather is so crappy it's kind of
rainy and then out of nowhere 20 people
showed up and it was almost like I
blinked and then there they were so it
gives me a lot of pride in my position
to know that I'm helping people come out
and do this type of work and they're
doing a lot not only to help the actual
city so that the beach gets cleaned up
but we're also doing bright work for the
things that can't advocate for
themselves like the wildlife in the area
or even the small children that come out
with their families to recreative the
Beach Discovery Channel Shark Week what
are you doing here we're here hoping to
clean up some beaches and you know
spread a little bit of awareness Ocean
Conservancy is a huge part of Sharpie
every year
obviously we really care about
conserving the world's oceans and you
know giving back to the community and
shark weeks an awesome fun program and
it's our 30th anniversary this year this
is definitely a huge part of what Shark
Week is meant to do is to kind of bring
awareness about what's going on in the
world in terms of the ocean you know we
were saying before a lot of people don't
always see this is like an urgent matter
but again when this stuff builds up and
people don't don't come together and
don't do what you're doing here today it
can be urgent it can have a really bad
impact on me I talked to a volunteer
once before when I first started at the
Alliance I said why do you do what you
do and the person said well if you see a
wildfire and you know that something bad
is happening because the ground is black
and it's charred the lakes don't
necessarily have the same type of effect
so it always looks kind of good but
unbeknownst to the naked eye there are
things that are going on they're not
necessarily always great that are
happening things like invasive species
or tiny pieces of trash that are
floating in the water that you can't see
or the fact that cigarette butts are
kind of the same color as sand it might
not look like it's dirty but I guarantee
you today will pick up over a hundred
pounds of debris off the beach today
we're hoping to make a healthy Great
Lakes for today tomorrow and forever I
want you to look at that camera there I
want you to tell the people if they want
to donate volunteer or just check out we
guys are about where can you go online
you can go online to wwx org to be
connected with the Alliance for the
Great Lakes hope to see you soon awesome
thank you so much man thank you for what
you're doing hey no problem
[Music]
[Laughter]